hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the pro chess League
it is Alexander shimanov versus Magnus
Carlsen and it's a wild game featuring
The Smith Mora Gambit and the Magnus is
on the receiving end of the smithmore
Gambit uh and uh that's that shouldn't
be a problem because it's not really a
Gambit that should pose you
um a severe severe problems but if you
don't know how to reply to everything
automatically you will have to look for
it over the board and its rapid chest
could be could be problematic so let's
see how Magnus deals with the Smith Mora
Gambit with E4 Yeah by Alexander Ponte
C5 Magnus goes for the Sicilian and now
the immediate D4 this is the Smith Mora
gamut and interestingly after uh after
uh uh Maura came up with the Gambit or
when he popularized it uh Ken Smith May
uh he created a couple of books and he
wrote a bunch of articles about it but
the first time he actually employed it
in a strong tournament in 1972 against a
very strong Grand Masters like Don burn
Larry Evans and Enrique making he lost
all of the games with it but he still
said it was it was a fine opening and
that you should know it so the four
wheel seek characters on the four Queen
captures uh and now Knight to C6
attacking the queen makes sense much
like you would have in a Scandinavian
defense uh that you brought the queen
too early in the game and the other
player will uh develop pieces with uh
attacks on the queen gaining Tempe so
here Queen D3 we have G6 by Magnus
Knight to C3 already a new move as of
move five so already as a move 5 we have
a completely new game Bishop to G7 with
Knight to F3 and Knight to F6 and now
Bishop to E2 we have castles castles and
now Pawn to D6 Knight to D5 and
excellent Square for the Knight if
Magnus wants to trade then this Pawn
will be a very strong um uh on D5
regarding the E6 and the C6 squares and
also you want to play C3 to limited the
power of the of the drag again sleeping
for the moment on G7 we have knighted D7
opening up the dragon and now Pawn to C3
we have Knight to C5 now attacking the
queen queen back the C to end E6 just uh
chases away the Knight um from D5
without any unnecessary trades uh
sunlight back to E3 Queen to C7 and now
Rook to D1 we have rooked d8 by Magnus
and now Pawn to B4 now you could have
played this uh move a few moves earlier
but okay uh Still Still final move 14 B4
we have Knight back to D7 and now Pawn
to A3 with Knight Dita E5 offering a
trade of knights and Bishop to B2 we
have captors and F3 captures on F3 and
now Pawn to A5 Magnus wants them uh ruin
a white nice uh queen size uh Pawn
structure uh we have Rook 8 to C1 and
now Bishop to D7 Magnus just continues
development with C4 uh now it's possible
to play this even though it looks like
the B4 Pawn is hanging uh but the B4
Pawn is never hanging so here eight
captures on B4 Bishop captures on g17
captures and a captures on B4 and now if
you capture then Queen to B to check
will uh win the Knight so of course
that's impossible Ponte E5 by Magnus
um you could also consider Knights the
E5 uh Pawn the E5 does give you the D4
Square for the Knight but it also gives
white the D5 Square for whitesnite and
this will be a bit problematic for
Magnus as you'll see he does go upon the
E5 with Knight the D5 attacks the queen
queen back to B8 and now comes Queen to
B2 here
uh White misses the the very strong Pawn
to B5 uh but a very similar thing
happens in the game so I guess it
doesn't really matter but here it was
possible just B5 Knight to D4 captures
captures and now Queen D3 going after
the pawn you will have access to the F6
Square uh this should be uh should be uh
Unstoppable I mean maybe you could
defend it with black but it will be very
hard especially in a rapid game uh
instead Queen to beat you was played
nicely aligning the queen with the black
king and G7 but now Bishop to E6 Ponte H
for Ponte H5 and now Pawn to B5 we have
Knight to D4 uh not right away uh first
the bishop captures uh on D5 eliminating
one of the attackers C captures on D5
and now Knight to the D4 but still Rook
captures on D4 here it's more of a
necessity than uh than an attack because
it was much much stronger in that
position he captures Queen capture
Sundee for King to G8 and now comes Pawn
to G4 the problem play something like B6
with the idea of something like Rook C7
Queen F6 there's always Rook C8 and now
your Rook isn't really doing all that
much so instead G4 uh here Alexander
wants to bust open the king side Rook
the C8 to grabbing open the the C file
we have Rook to E1 and now H Captain sng
for Bishop captures with Rook to C2 and
now Ponte H5 can Magnus survive this
attack we have Queen to A7 it's
important to get the queen uh into the
game somehow offering a queen trade of
course Alexander declines now he's
hoping to get H captures on G6 in or
even H6 uh how are you stopping
Checkmate here Magnus finds a very very
clean idea Queen to A5 you want to
re-maneuver the queen over to d8 but you
have to do it via the A5 Square
so now the Rook on E1 is hanging you
don't have time for H6 because then you
just start gobbling up everything so
here we have rooked the F1 uh definitely
the the strongest move as it will keep
the F2 Pawn safe now comes Queen to d8
offering a queen trade and now Queen
back to F4 and now Magnus plays Queen to
E7 uh which uh is is definitely a
possibility Queen to f8 was somewhat
stronger as a counter's captors would
immediately uh be offering a queen trade
but okay after Queen F4 Queen t7 by
Magnus H captors F captures and now
Queen to H6 putting pressure on the G6
pawn queen G7 and now Bishop to E6 check
we have King to f8 and here Queen to G5
leaving Magnus with a very very tricky
position where he's up the exchange but
there's just not all that much to do and
in fact it's very hard to find the move
here especially if you're low on time as
they both were here so here Queen to E5
is the move you you probably should play
you offer a queen trade and the queen
trade is always favorable for for black
and the best you could hope for is
something like Queen to H6 check and
some sort of a repetition because if you
if you capture the pawn then this forces
a queen trade so that's a problem so
probably we would see something like
Queen H6 check Queen G7 Queen back to G5
and then maybe even a repetition uh but
here Rook the C4 was played by Magnus he
wants to continue pushing now comes king
sorry not King d8 uh King to G2 uh we
have Rook captures on e4 and now Rook
the H1 uh grabbing hold of the open H
file and now comes Rook to E5 by Magnus
which is very strong just not the
strongest here the way to defend this
was King to E8 it looks like a silly
move because there's uh really nowhere
for you to go the queen covers the dark
squares the bishop covers the light
squares but you do get out of this very
nasty Rook H3 Rook to F3 check and here
if white persists for example you could
play Rook to A4 and now even if Rook the
C3 now threatening Rook to C8 but also
offering The Rook with Queen captures on
C3 uh it's impossible because if you
capture then you just get Queen captures
on G6 check King goes here Queen to Jade
with check King has to go to C7 now
Queen to C8 to check
uh will pick up the queen and C3 so that
uh is not possible you can't capture The
Rook however what you can play is this
Rook to G for check move you force the
bishop out of E6 and then only after
Bishop captures now you play Queen
captures and C3 now it's much different
Queen captures than G6 now you can go to
E7 if Queen T6 check you just go to f8
it's not a problem and there's just not
enough Queen captures and this is King
the G7 and the white will have to settle
for a repetition so that's why King the
E8 is the move here but in a rapid time
format with little time on the clock uh
you just don't find such a move Magnus
played the second best move by the
engine but this is much much harder to
hold Queen to F4 with check and now
comes King to E7 by Magnus it's a very
interesting dude if King to E8 then
white is just completely winning and
it's very interesting why uh feel free
to pause the video and try to solve this
hypothetical position while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course a rook to h8 with check you
sacrifice The Rook to free up the F7
Square for the queen and that's it now
you either move the king and then you
lose the rook and A8 so it's just a game
over or you capture and then it's a nice
mating too so that would that would be
winning that's why after Queen to F4
check Magnus played King to E7 but
congratulations of course to everyone
who realized why he played that and now
Rook to C1 uh The Rook is now coming the
the C7 and you will very much like to
either win the black queen or Checkmate
the black king So King back to E8 and
now Pawn to B6 preparing Rook to C7 and
here Magnus plays Pawn to G5 best way to
hold was just Quinta uh Queen to E7 but
again it's a very hard move to spot
Queen E7 you have to see that you have
this check and you you force a queen
trade but the G5 was played and now
comes Queen to G4 Quinta H6 by Magnus
and now the game is completely winning
but luckily for Magnus Alexander misses
it he goes for Rook to C7 a move that he
was trying to throw in as for so very
long uh the way the win this is Rook H1
and now there's just no defense here you
have to play Queen G7 to stop Rook to AJ
to check but now Queen H5 check and
after King 38 you play Queen to h8 to
check and it's pretty much the same
thing Queen captures you're gonna play
Rook captures King has to go to E7 and
then Rook capture 78 White will just be
up a full piece so instead after Rook H6
a rook the C7 was played it's not as
deadly but it is very very hard to hold
for Magnus Magnus would have to find a
queen to H4 to hold this but a Magnus
played Rook the A1 he wanted to go for a
checkmating attack himself but now again
it is completely winning it's actually a
force made in five but even if you don't
find it the force made in five uh pretty
much any move is a winning Bishop the D7
check is winning Rook to see it check is
winning but Bishop to F7 check is the
move that Alexander plane and now it's
just a meeting made in five uh King
David was played Queen to C8 with check
the King has to go under the mask of the
rocking G7 now Bishop P6 check King to
F6 and now Queen to d8 with check King
to G6 and now the very strong Queen to
E8 with check and he was in this
position on move 51 that Magnus Carlsen
resigned to the game as there was
nothing more to be done here King to F6
has to be played and then Queen to F7
will of course beat Checkmate so uh
although uh like I said the smithmore
Gambit might not be the the strongest uh
weapon when it comes to whether it's
objectively the strongest but as you can
see it can surprise the world champion
and you can win a nice game checkmating
him uh like this or you know he will
resign before you actually deliver
Checkmate on the board and let me just
check real quickly I don't want to trick
you guys on how the match actually went
uh let me just uh check real quick yeah
yeah the camera of the chess bras Drew
against levit of Chess Wizards as we've
seen the game Magnus played against
Alexander kostenyuk but Shimon of uh by
winning this very nice game against
Magnus Carlsen in the end the day
they drew the match so very nicely done
and a very important victory for the for
the Wizards uh so yeah there we have it
hope you guys enjoyed it if you like it
do do try the Smith Moro Gambit let me
know how it goes it's it's a very
exciting company much much like the
scotch Gambit like you just want to bust
open the center and you know play chess
uh no no funny business uh so yeah one
thing I really hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Lobo ravishing
reptiles YouTube uh Jill Wilders and
Ryan Cavanaugh for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day